what's up everyone this is Anthony
papiano
most of you know me as pump you're
listening to off the chain
simply the best podcasting crypto let's
kick this thing off
Emily Parker is the co-founder of long
hash in this conversation we talked
about how journalism has changed over
time what the day-to-day schedule of
policy planning staff looks like how
power is not a top-down phenomenon
anymore what the internet censorship in
China really looks like
how long has is trying to serve as a
gateway to Asia and what exactly data
journalism is I really enjoyed this
conversation and I hope you do as well
skirt school want to know who has the
best URL crypto comm that's right
crypto comm they're a crypto platform
with one goal [ __ ] mass adoption
that's why we're all here we're trying
to get crypto in every wallet curve
dot-com is helping people do that
through buying earning lending and card
payment everything you could want at
crypto comm go help your boy out
tell them pump sent you download the app
or visit crypto com pumps got you always
everyone to get into mining and didn't
know how don't worry
your boy pops gotcha everybody got some
electricity and Wi-Fi all you got to do
is go to coin mine comm you buy a coin
mine it's like an Xbox or a Playstation
that helps you turn your electricity
into Bitcoin that's right you purchase
it it shows up at your doorstep you pull
it out of the box you plug it in connect
to your Wi-Fi five minutes or less
you're mining Bitcoin all you have to do
is control it from the mobile app they
provide and then you receive
over-the-air updates that add new coins
and new features on a consistent basis
kind of like how Tesla does over-the-air
updates and updates the car software
just you're updating your coin mind
consumer mining made easy that's right
go to coin mine comm tell them tom sent
you and thank me later as many of you
know crypto investors store their
digital assets on exchanges or in cold
storage for long-term safekeeping
however this strategy doesn't help them
grow their investment holdings or build
overall wealth
with the new block by interest account
users can now securely store their
Bitcoin or ether at block five and
receive 6% annual interest paid monthly
and cryptocurrency 6% is an absurdly
high rate it's the best rate in the
industry I highly suggest you go check
out block Viacom / pump again that's
block 5 com / pop to sign up and start
earning crypto today if you follow
Bitcoin and crypto
you've probably heard of eToro they're
the world's number one social trading
platforms and I love it they've got more
than 10 million other traders that love
it - and guess what they just launched
the United States eToro offers access to
the world's most popular crypto
currencies including Bitcoin etherium
and others with the smortest trading
tools and the ability to connect with
the best traders around the world
there's no better place to build your
perfect portfolio if you're new to
Bitcoin and crypto you can test the
waters with their $100,000 virtual
trading feature but if you're more
experienced you can create custom
technical charts and use eToro social
fees to inform your trading decisions
they've got transparent fees and so you
never miss out they also have an
easy-to-use application available on
iPhone Android or any web browser you
can get started today in just a few
clicks
at each or com again that's eToro comm
get VIP access to Bitcoin and crypto
markets today Anthony pomp lion-o is a
partner at Morgan Creek Digital all
opinions expressed by pump or his guests
on this podcast are solely their
opinions and do not reflect the opinions
of Morgan Creek digital or Morgan Creek
Capital Management you should not treat
any opinion expressed by pomp as a
specific inducement to make a particular
investment or follow a particular
strategy but only as an expression of
his opinion this podcast is for
informational purposes only
alright guys bang bang I've got Emily
here I am super excited to have this
conversation she's got a really unique
view of the world both kind of the
intersection of data journalism and then
Asian markets so thanks so much for
taking time dudes thank you so much for
having me
let's start with your background
you've done a whole bunch of cool stuff
in the past
we're kind of did you get started go to
school and what you do after that
sure thanks so much so I actually
started becoming interested in China
fairly early I started studying Chinese
in high school and then continued doing
that in college and right after college
I moved to Japan and after that I
started at The Wall Street Journal I was
in there Hong Kong office and we were
basically covering Asia and at that time
I became very interested in China and
the internet specifically looking at the
the impact of the Internet in China and
that's been kind of the through line of
my career China and technology after the
Wall Street Journal I moved on to the
New York Times then I left staff
journalism I wrote a book looking at the
impact of the Internet and the social
and social media in China Cuba and
Russia the book is called now I know who
my comrades are I also worked at the
State Department on the policy planning
staff and I was advising on technology
policy so that was kind of in the midst
of the Internet freedom agenda and the
US was looking at how to use the
Internet and social media as a foreign
policy tool got it how um how is
journalism changed over time one of the
biggest changes of course is social
media I think it's in some ways
journalism has become a lot more
democratic which is a good thing I think
before there are a lot more gatekeepers
to journalism now everyone has a voice
obviously that has both good sides and
bad sides the good is that yes there are
more voices in journalism the bad side
is that there are accuracy problems and
trust problems and it's it's it's hard
to know who to believe and I think also
right now a lot of the mainstream media
has a credibility problem and that you
have a lot of the country not believing
certain news outlets for sure and I
guess you parlayed that into the work
with the State Department obviously talk
a little bit about what the policy
planning staff does and kind of what
does that look the day-to-day as you
look at various issues especially around
technology sure so the policy planning
staff it changes a lot with different
administrations when I was there it was
it had some people like me who came from
outside of government who had a specific
area background and we were there to
advise on a specific topic if so mine
was technology and
your net freedom so it's kind of a big
picture thinking part of the state
Department where you're sort of looking
at what are these policy means what does
this policy mean what is the general
direction the US government should be
moving in in a certain area so it's a
little bit less on the day-to-day detail
level and a little bit more on the big
picture strategic thinking level so this
was sort of now everyone takes for
granted that there are a lot of US
officials on Twitter and obviously a
very well-known US official on Twitter
but um when I was at the State
Department that was kind of just getting
started where the State Department was
trying to figure out like how should we
use social media and it was a really
interesting culture clash because you
have these bureaucrats who are very
nervous about speaking directly to the
public and everything has to be
controlled but then you have social
media which is the complete opposite of
that so it was I was sort of there in
the middle of that transition I'll just
say Trump's wild on Twitter he's
absolutely and I think use the word wild
specifically because there's some things
where he's probably actually accurate in
somewhere he's not accurate but just the
idea that the president of the United
States can speak to he's got pride tens
of millions of followers directly there
is no fact-checking there is no spin
there is no kind of media filter if you
will yeah this is exactly what he wants
to say to the people good bad or
indifferent we've just never had that
before we've never had that before
that's absolutely right and I think now
it's become people are just used to it
or I mean they complain about it but
they're used to the idea that we have a
president speaking directly to the
people but yeah I mean if you look even
like ten years ago this was a crazy idea
because the State Department and
government in general they operate on
press releases and well-coordinated
statements where everybody has to sign
off and get buy-in and now you literally
have people speaking directly to the
world via their phone and it's hard to
overstate how huge a change that is and
it's a very recent change for sure in
the part that cracks me up is it's not
just the president right whoever the
president would like that kind of
cracked it open you know we're recording
this right after one of there was a
democratic debate recently and I saw on
Twitter that
bill o'reilly called out one of the
candidates beta or auric and then beta
O'Rourke basically came and like dumped
on him on Twitter right and I was just
sitting there thinking like literally
five six seven years ago the power in
version was the media had all of the
power they basically were the filter for
the information that was going to the
people now you have you know the reverse
now Bill's got some problems and and
it's no longer really the truthful media
but you now have the candidates that are
controlling the narrative and it's
almost like the media players have
become a part of the story yes right yes
I think that's absolutely right and you
know I think this all reflects just a
larger change is happening in the world
which is that power is much less of a
top-down phenomenon so I think the big
shift to social media that started
happening around the time of the Arab
Spring for example when these huge
changes in the world were not happening
behind closed doors and governments they
were happening people on the ground in
large cases using social media to make
change happen and I think some of the
changes in government are just
reflecting that I think it was around
that time that the US government
realized okay we can't really do
business in the old way anymore it just
doesn't work we have to speak directly
to the people or the people are just
gonna do their own thing so I think they
realize like we have to get on social
media we have to speak directly to the
public but now it's kind of been taken
to a new level and you're totally right
I mean it's not just it's not just
politicians speaking to the public it's
it's different governments speaking to
each other on social media while the
whole world watches and chimes in so
this is a completely new era and it's
again it's fairly recent well it cracks
me up because it's kind of like you got
Wendy's and Twitter and McDonald's you
know fighting it out on Twitter like
eventually you're gonna have the US and
you know if you go back to the Trump
stuff probably the wildest moment for me
was when he started tweeting at the
North Korean dictator saying calling
them little rocket man right and it's
like it's funny but it's also got
serious consequences and you're
basically you know you're toeing the
line between like a a political type of
relationship or negotiation right and
kind of the it with the rule book what
an ambassador would normally do yeah
and you're combining that with the power
to like start a war yeah right and then
you add in the nuclear power and let you
start doing all this different stuff and
it just becomes a very complex issue
that I don't think there's a
black-and-white answer to and so like
we're all kind of learning as this thing
is playing out here yeah we've really
got from one extreme to the other so I
think the negative side before was that
a lot of the public felt that the
government was really opaque and that
these kinds of conversations were not
transparent now you could argue that
maybe they're a little bit too
transparent I mean these things are
happening in real time
and yeah I mean when you look at the way
foreign policy used to be conducted
there was planning there was buy-in
there were a lot of different
departments had to agree on a specific
stance now it's like kind of all gone
rogue right I mean everyone he's just
sort of saying things and and also I
think before at least in the US
government side there was more of a US
government position you didn't have all
these individual personalities on
Twitter where you would know so deeply
what a specific ambassador was like or
what a specific politician was like
because they were representing a larger
entity but I think Twitter is allowing
more for these like individual voices to
be heard and it has its benefits and it
also has its drawbacks yeah one of my
partner's always says a friend of his
said to him I reminisce about the days
when I didn't know the name of the
central bankers right yes same thing
could be said in terms of the Ambassador
ships etc like the fact that we could
name you know the controversial figures
and what they're doing etc it's just a
deeper level of information how did you
originally come across crypto Bitcoin
etc in terms of you were a journalist
you were focused on China and some
technology but what was kind of the
first foray into Bitcoin and crypto sure
so just one other point though that you
referenced earlier I think you know
right now we talk about this whole idea
of you know social media and and how a
lot of the negative sides but it does
have a positive side too and you
referenced this earlier which is that
there were a lot of people who felt left
out of the media narrative you know both
in the United States and in other
countries they felt that their stories
weren't being told by the media and so
social media is a chance for a lot of
people to get their stories out and so
that's kind of related to your other
questions so I had been looking at the
impact of the internet in China for
a long time and early on you know that
China has always had a lot of Internet
censorship but the other thing about
China is information is always managed
to get through no matter how much they
censor there's always information that
gets through it's just impossible for
any one government to completely control
the Internet it's just not possible and
so I just became interested in on that
level just kind of looking at this
tension between decentralized technology
and government controls and I started to
notice you know kind of around 2017 how
big crypto was in China crypto was huge
in China I mean it was it was it was a
huge part of global trade and then of
course the Chinese authorities got
nervous and they tried to ban various
aspects of the cryptocurrency industry
and my feeling was having watched the
space for a long time I was like okay
this is gonna be like an epic battle
right because before you had the
internet spreading information and the
government trying to rein that in I was
like okay now you have Bitcoin kind of
spreading decentralized money the
government's gonna try to rein that in
and so what have you seen actually
happen in China or actually before we go
into that let's back up for a second
explain what you're doing in terms of
building a company or its long hash and
you're kind of you've got a couple of
different irons in the fire if you will
but explain exactly what you guys are
doing and then we'll get into kind of
your perspective but I want people to
understand first kind of where you're
coming from sure so long edge does do a
lot of different things but like our
general vision is that we see ourselves
as a gateway to Asia because we believe
that Asia is really the heart of the
cryptocurrency world and it's a little
bit hard to understand from outside of
the region and so we have offices in
Shanghai Tokyo Hong Kong and Singapore
and we have you know people in all those
places and people who really really
understand those those locations so long
- it has two parts one part is a data
journalism platform which basically so
the idea behind the data journalism
platform is quite simple
everyone always in the crypto industry
talks about how much data there is right
that's the blockchain is data you
everything you know people say the great
thing about blockchain is that you can
see all this data but the number of
people that actually understand that
data or can use that data is actually
very small this isn't like an easy thing
to make sense of and so well how we see
data journalism is we take that data
tell stories around it and we explained
to investors what they should pay
attention to and and why should they
care and our and our platform also has a
little bit more of a focus on the Asian
markets and then the other part of Leung
hash is we also have we also do
incubation of early-stage startups and
help them kind of break into the asian
market and we also help asian startups
kind of go global go the other way yes
yeah uh describe what data journalism is
I think it's a little bit different and
we were joking beforehand most people I
think when they hear the word data
journalism it's I'm gonna write an
article and I'm gonna include like a
graph yeah so what exactly is data
journalist yeah well I think there are
different definitions so the way that I
see it is that I think one of the
problems is that there's this kind of
this big gap in that obviously you have
a lot of people doing data out there are
a lot of data scientists but they don't
necessarily know how to communicate
their ideas to a mainstream audience you
know they'll kind of hand you the data
and say okay you figure it out and then
on the other hand you have a lot of
great journalists but they're not
necessarily familiar with data so we're
actually working with data scientists
who can take that data and tell stories
around it it's really I guess the
simplest way to answer your question is
I see data journalism as telling stories
around Nina so it's based in data we
definitely use charts we use on chain
data we use price data but we don't just
put it out there we don't just put it
out there for people to make sense of we
try to actually tell a story around it
tell a narrative around it because I
feel like without that the data isn't
very useful to most people because you
just look at data and it's not just
saying it's not just explaining the data
it's saying you know what does this data
mean and also why is this data more
important than other data I mean this is
this is something that I'd say most
people can't necessarily make sense of
for sure and we're why is this valuable
right in the sense of I think that I at
least see it usually as two separate
things right so you have the the
journalism that goes on let's say in
Kryptonian at the coin desk the coin
Telegraph's of the world then there's
the data journalism that goes on we
don't see a little humor section of the
- yeah at least externally you know
looking in it at these different
platforms why is that and and is that a
good thing or a bad thing sorry
looking at the data journalism versus
wrong call more traditional - yeah no
I think you're absolutely right and this
is not just a crypto industry thing this
is just an industry thing where you know
again there's this very big gulf between
kind of the data people and the
journalists right I mean they're there
they're kind of two different skill sets
and we're trying to create almost like a
hybrid where you have a combination of
data and storytelling so I think yeah we
are different from a lot of these crypto
platforms but I think generally just
because traditionally these two ways of
telling stories have been very very
separated I think you know data
scientists in general are not trained to
you know create narratives around data
and journalists are not necessarily
trained to understand data at a very
deep level so you kind of have to create
something something new it's kind of a
very new new field in general got it and
so let's talk about Asia specifically
with crypto like what do you see just at
a high level
right you're talking to an American and
or somebody from the Western world they
say I know nothing about Asia but I'm
super into Bitcoin and crypto what do I
need to know and what are they like two
to three high-level points that you see
that are really important and kind of
articulate the Asian markets to that
Western audience sure so again Asian
Asia's you know quite big and so I can I
think the countries that we focus on the
most are China Japan and Singapore I
mean I guess we would say quite simply
is that this is a really big market I
mean that's the simplest way to say it
it's a really big market understatement
of the year yeah it's a huge market and
and also it's there is the chance that
at least in the near term we might see
more dynamism there than than in the
United States that's possible and a lot
of that has to do with regulation I
think a lot of blockchain projects are
really afraid of the US or they think
that the u.s. is too strict and more
important they think regulations in the
US are unclear like it's unclear what is
the utility what is the security and so
you know you hear stories I mean some of
this is anecdotal but I think we will
eventually see some data on this of
blockchain projects kind of leaving the
US and and going to Asia and registering
Asia because they think that's more of a
friendly dynamic you know whether this
is good or bad it's hard to say I mean
you know it's hard to say with the US I
mean this doesn't necessarily have to be
a permanent thing the big question for
the u.s. is like
okay are we just getting our house in
order we're being strict we're making
sure that like you know this doesn't
become a total meltdown or is there just
kind of like regulatory confusion you
know I think it's kind of a combination
of both I mean I don't think it's bad to
be strict on regulation but there needs
to be a little bit more clarity and
actually the the SEC Commissioner Hester
first visited Asia and I met her there
and one of her observations was that you
know the US has just just has a lack of
clarity in the encrypted regulation
space that it's just really hard to make
sense of and I think that contrasts to a
place like Singapore where I think
people have just a better sense of kind
of what's going on and regulators are
seen as looking at cryptocurrency more
as an opportunity then as a threat so I
think that's I think those are the big
things that's a huge market and that it
in may in the short term be perceived as
more of a regulation friendly
environment and then the United States
obviously not China but but China is
still trying to steal a very big big
market mm-hmm for sure and when you look
at from a data standpoint like what are
the key things to look at right when it
comes is this something like hey what's
the active wallet addresses on Bitcoin
in certain markets is this volume on
exchanges is there other metrics you you
guys look at like what like what are
those key metrics tool yeah great
question I only do great questions on
this yeah it's great question um so
shout out to all the Twitter trolls who
like that when I say that I think that
geographical data can be very very
challenging this is one of the big
challenges in blockchain is just in the
blockchain world which is just isolating
like what country activity is having is
happening in but there are certain
things like for example I mean one one
statistic that I think it's um a data
sight coin called coin Hill's looks at
national trade between Bitcoin and
various national national currencies so
you know US as of recently u.s. dollar
was number one the Japanese yen was
number two that's a pretty I think
that's pretty interesting I mean that
kind of shows how big the Japanese
market is yeah um you know Japan from
what I've heard is is pretty much a
retail market those are retail traders
there's not a lot of institutional money
in crypto there
yeah that's kind of one statistic I
think Japan they've had a lot of
regulatory swings over the past two
years but I think it's a market that we
should really take seriously because
there's just a lot of retail traders
there um
China is very difficult to get accurate
volume on because China has cracked down
on cryptocurrency exchanges we do know
that trade volume was huge and you know
2016-2017 before that happened but you
know what we try to do with Chinese we
try to look at other metrics like social
media we look at like search you know
it's a search traffic for Bitcoin or
other words like that we also look at
how often you know these terms are
mentioned on Chinese social media so and
then if you just look at kind of want to
look at activity in the region a
Singapore recently I Singapore had as of
last year in August 2018 this is element
dis data you know them um Singapore had
more I SEOs than the United States so I
think that's that's pretty interesting
right if you look at the size of
Singapore versus the United States this
is you know this is a data point I
mentioned often because I think it
really shows the changes that are
happening in the world for sure and so
I'm very fond of this idea that it the
best investors in the world understand
demographic changes and they basically
bet on those changes right so there are
certain countries in the world that our
growth countries versus not a lot of it
is you can see by the demographics of
the country right are they growing are
they not growing all this stuff what is
the age population at the median and
average ages old Vanessa is some of this
a demographic driven difference between
Asia and let's call it the Western world
or the United States meaning that
there's just younger larger populations
in Asia that are super interested in
this stuff and they now have access to
the Internet and they're in there kind
of digitally native or is it something
else
right like how much of it is what I all
consider like a structurally driven
difference versus no actually it's just
a cultural thing or something else
that's driving this yeah so I think
that's definitely part of it the
demographics but I think a lot of it is
a lot of it does have to do with the
government approach to cryptocurrencies
I think you know when you really
government-driven well I want to say
it's government driven but I think that
plays a role so I think I know in the US
where you have this feeling that the US
government's really nervous about
cryptocurrency and they're kind of
trying to keep it from getting out of
control and then you have a place like
Singapore which is sort of welcoming and
I think Singapore really sees
cryptocurrencies blockchain is a huge
opportunity like this is gonna be our
thing like we are really going to
embrace this so I definitely think that
that's part of it and I think yeah I
think in you know in a country like
China for example it's just a really
it's a different place for people to
park their money it's it's a different
way for people to invest that like
offers a pretty strong contrast to the
other options that are out there so you
know I think it's these are yes very
very different contexts
you know scoot Scoob I want to know who
has the best URL crypto calm that's
right
crypto calm there are crypto platform
with one goal 'mother mass adoption
that's why we're all here we're trying
to get crypto in every wallet crypto
calm is helping people do that through
buying earning lending and card payment
everything you could want at crypto calm
go help your boy out
tell them pomp sense you download the
app or visit crypto comm pumps got you
always everyone to get into mining and
didn't know how don't worry your boy
pops gotcha everybody got some
electricity and Wi-Fi all you got to do
is go to coin mine comm you buy a coin
mine it's like an Xbox or a PlayStation
that helps you turn your electricity
into Bitcoin that's right you purchase
it it shows up at your doorstep you pull
it out of the box
you plug it in connect to your Wi-Fi
five minutes or less you're mining
Bitcoin all you have to do is control it
from the mobile app they provide and
then you receive over-the-air updates
that add new coins and new features on a
consistent basis kind of like how Tesla
does over-the-air updates and updates
the car software just you're updating
your coin mind consumer mining made easy
that's right go to coin mine com tell
them pump Sencha and thank me later
one more word from our sponsor blocked
by their new interest account allows you
to securely deposit your Bitcoin or
Ethernet block by and receive 6% annual
interest paid monthly and cryptocurrency
this rate actually compounds
you receive a 6.2% APY which is very
attractive given the alternatives so you
can actually take your Bitcoin you can
deposit it with block Phi and get paid
an interest rate of 6% in return go
check out block 5 comm / pop again block
5 comm / pump to sign up and start
earning interest on your crypto today
and so as you continue to look at this
you're seeing more and more US projects
go to Asia right now is this they're
actually leaving the u.s. to go to Asia
or they're saying hey I'm a us-based
company or organization and I want to
establish myself in it yeah like how do
you see kind of the connection of those
u.s. initiated organizations and the
Asian markets yeah I think both are
happening so you know and this is
something that the SEC Commissioner
actually said to me and she said that
she's hearing projects are basically
avoiding the u.s. so that can be of
course they are yeah so so right so
there's there's all sorts of reasons I
mean I think you know you also hear
about a lot of and I've heard this just
anecdotally about projects that you know
don't want to accept US users won't let
us US buyers buy tokens but they're open
to other markets I mean you just hear
stories like this all the time and I
think again the point to underscore here
is it's not necessarily because the u.s.
is more strict it's because the u.s. is
confusing the u.s. is very confusing
because you know if you look at
Singapore you know there generally is
one regulatory body that like looks
after these things the US has like a
bunch of different regulatory bodies and
different states have different rules
and you have things like the Howey test
you know what is where you kind of need
to be a securities lawyer to figure out
what's going on at least that's the
impression I mean some people will say
no the u.s. is clear I'm sure some
people would argue that but I think the
general impression among a lot of
blockchain projects is that it's not
clear and that you could run afoul of US
law like accidentally you know and
that's like who wants to take that risk
right that's a pretty big risk it's you
know cryptocurrency is already pretty
confusing and it's already you know
regulations are already very slippery
you know why would you want to operate
in a jurisdiction where you could just
like accidentally get in trouble with
the SEC and I do think there is some
level of that I also think that just you
know again in Singapore there's this
feeling that like you can approach
regulators and they kind of want to talk
to you and I
people say the u.s. is a little bit more
more scary I don't think this
necessarily has to be the case forever
but I do think that that's the
impression now this is something I hear
a lot about got it and so does that
change over time what can we actually
get the clarity in the US and almost
incentivize those people back or do you
think that this is something where the
epicenter of this industry has shifted
to Asia and there's no pulling it back
because now you have a kind of a
snowball rolling downhill rate that too
many people too connected to incentivize
to be in Asia to stay there the
liquidities there etc and you'll never
pull the epicenter back to the US or or
is it possible to actually do that oh I
think it's definitely possible to change
I think this is so dynamic I mean this
is just changing so quickly I mean even
in just two years I've seen so many
changes so you know for example you had
China being kind of the center of the
Bitcoin world that was definitely
happening you know about 2016 then China
cracks down then a lot of those
investors migrate to Japan and Korea
then early 2018 Japan suffers the
biggest hack in crypto exchange history
they lost 500 million dollars this was
coin check then Japan gets really strict
this is something people don't
necessarily pay that much attention to
here but Japan has been kind of in a
crypto freeze for a while they really
got very strict after that hack and then
that's when you start to see kind of
everybody talking about Singapore so
I've already seen all these changes
happening it can it can kind of change
on a dime right because all you need is
like one bad thing to happen in one of
these countries and then they can
completely change their policy on on
crypto and I think what the US a lot of
it is going to just depend on like how
regulate or see this industry right do
they see it as a threat or do they see
it as an opportunity I mean again if you
look at this SEC Commissioner if you
look at Hester purse she's she's one of
the people really sees this as an
opportunity because I asked her this
question I said why do you care if
crypto leaves the u.s. does this even
matter and she said it matters because I
don't want to lose a whole generation of
talent that's her thinking but I don't
think a lot of US officials don't see it
like that because they're thinking about
the financial crisis and they're
thinking like what if something goes
horribly wrong we don't want this to be
our fault right so a lot of it is gonna
have to be you know I think look some
strictness is good right I mean there
are a lot of scams in the ico world
right and so I don't think it's bad to
be strict
this but I think you have to be clear
you know and and that's something that
yeah I do think it can change but they
have to kind of want it to change and
they have to really see this is
something that like will help the u.s.
in the long run and I think you know
Singapore sees sees crypto and
blockchain is something that will help
them in the long run I think Japan
ultimately will see it that way although
they've been kind of going back and
forth so a lot of it is gonna just
depend on like if they see this is it's
worth fixing yep absolutely it makes
complete sense what are you most excited
about in Asia right so there's a whole
bunch of stuff going on there's projects
that are coming from the US that are
going there there's a lot of stuff
organically being built but like
somebody who spends a lot of your time
you're fluent in multiple languages on
the in different countries what gets you
excited well I think it just it's just
the energy in Asia it's just very very
dynamic and you know you just see so
many projects going there you see a lot
of innovation happening I mean even in a
country like China I think the headlines
here you know we're all about China
banning this or China banning that but
there's just like a lot of
entrepreneurial energy kind of at the
grassroots level and so that's what gets
me excited about Asia I mean it just the
size of the market is exciting because
this is just I mean if we're talking
about Bitcoin mass adoption and we're
talking about you know this really
becoming a big thing you need a shoe
right and I think this is something that
you know these markets are really really
big big players and I think so I think
the attitude towards cryptocurrency
again seeing it as an opportunity and
the market size and then also just like
yeah the entrepreneurial activity that
I'm seeing there is very exciting it
feels it feels like it's also the speed
and again speed is a double-edged sword
right because speed you know you have to
be careful because if there's too much
speed then like mistakes can happen and
scams can happen but you do get the
sense that in in in Asia things are
moving very very quickly and you know
it's it's exciting it's exciting to see
like how just how much they're
innovating and I think sometimes you
know in a situation like China for
example where there are a lot of
barriers people almost have to innovate
more right they have to kind of come up
with like creative creative solutions
and so it's just it's just a very very
dynamic space the u.s. seems like a
little kamar you know by comparison
yeah and looking in a disruptive market
being calmer might not be a good thing
right like it actually may be a negative
to some degree this is sort of the
our question right so it's like right I
mean again it's it's if you move too
fast and if you cut corners like really
bad things can happen I mean we know
this from you know the financial world
but right there is this danger that if
you move too slowly you will get left
behind and other countries will will
leapfrog you so I think this is really
this is the question for regulators all
over the world that's it that's and and
for me as someone who comes from the
policy world into this that's kind of
what I find the most interesting is that
tension right like that tension that
every government is facing which is like
okay this is this crazy technology this
is a currency that we can't control I
mean think about it from a government
perspective right I mean it's really
radical you know I mean this is a this
is a currency that it's out of the scope
of government control so as a government
you're gonna be a little bit nervous
about that right but at the same time
you recognize that it's probably
unstoppable and it's going to happen
anyway so like how do you strike that
balance between like you know having it
not be a threat to your sovereignty but
also like not shutting it down so it's
like I'm sympathetic to government
regulators I mean this is like not an
easy thing to figure out and especially
for a country like the US which arguably
has a lot to lose right I mean you know
this is that's the other thing I mean
the u.s. is in a different situation
right so do you think investors in the
u.s. are making a mistake if they only
invest in the u.s. like is it to the
point where there's so much going on in
Asia that ignoring that part of the
world could actually have a material
impact on returns and I don't want to
say it's fatal for an investment
organization but would be highly
detrimental I think it is really
important to look outside of the US
however I think you have to be really
careful because if you know and this is
kind of what we try to do at Long Kesh
this is this is why we call ourselves a
gateway to Asia because we really try to
help people enter those markets and
understand those markets because you
know even if you look at you know China
or Japan for various reasons these are
not markets that are easy to just kind
of helicopter into you know it's just
it's it's it's you know partly about
evaluating the projects but also just
knowing who you're dealing with I mean
there's a lot of trusses necessary a lot
of networks are necessary so yeah I do
think it's important to invest in these
markets but I think you have to know I
think you have to know what you're doing
because I think if you don't know what
you're doing I mean this is true in
general but I think especially when
you're operating in a foreign
environment if you don't know what
you're doing you can get pretty
you're being incredibly kind I'll just
say there's a lot of Americans who think
that if they go to Asia and investigate
scammed right they don't understand like
basically is what you're saying they
don't understand the market they don't
understand the dynamics they don't know
that the players are they don't speak
the language right there's all these
hurdles and so there's a lot of people
just throw their hands up and say look
rather than try to figure all this out
like the odds of capital loss are so
high that there's no amount of upside
potential that could convince me to take
the risks that I perceive to be taking I
think what you're the point you're
making is no you can actually mitigate a
lot of those risks either by getting
educated through certain things by
having teams on the ground you know all
these aspects but takes real capital
commitment and real kind of intellectual
commitment to spend the time to do or
find good partners you know and again
that's really something that we are
really trying to do you know we have
teams on the ground in Asia we have we
have some funding from the Singapore
government we're like a very trusted
entity in Asia because it's all about
trust at the end of the day all those
things can be avoided if you're working
with people you trust and you're working
with people who have kind of like good
reputations and good backgrounds of this
area but I mean look in general you know
anytime you're coming from one country
to another there's just so many things
that are happy there's always a back
there's always a back story you know
there's always things that are very hard
to know unless you kind of like have
experience or people you trust in that
area how serious is the perceived China
ban on Bitcoin is that something that's
heavily enforced or is that kind of yeah
yeah we banned it but oh by the way let
me buy something I think you will get a
completely different answer in the
United States and in China so if you say
if you ask that question to Americans
they're gonna say it's a huge deal it's
a black box it's it's it's it's really
this ban is really serious if you ask
people in China a lot of them are gonna
be like it's fine they're used to
everything yeah I think this is just
what I mean I think one of the key
lessons about China is that it always
looks really different from the outside
and from the inside always so you know
constantly and it's it's it's it's
actually it makes your head spin it is a
big deal I mean China actually took
pretty pretty radical steps by you know
kind of banning you know the exchanges
from training from Chinese currency
typically that's a pretty big deal from
banning icos the ico ban is definitely
pretty
and I don't think it's necessarily a bad
thing actually a lot of people in the
Chinese crypto world supported that ban
so it's not like I'm on I don't want to
downplay what China did but I think
there can be this the sense here in the
US like okay that market is is dead
which is just not true but the other
problem is that there's not a lot of
data so I know it's not true and if
you're in China you know it's not true
but there's not a lot of good data to
support it because the exchanges you
don't have that exchange data to you
know to support that how vibrant that
market is so it is it is like
legitimately confusing you know what's
happening in China is the China Hong
Kong situation playing into any of this
like that drawing attention to Bitcoin
or crypto or is that more of a kind of
American narrative that people want to
believe but not actually playing out
really it's really hard to say because
you know it's just hard to get data on
something like that right you like you
just don't know because there's so many
different it's like the trade war right
I mean you know it's it's and we tried
to do analysis of this but it's always
there's always going to be a little bit
of murkiness you know like is this
specific political event driving more
people into Bitcoin I think it's always
hard to prove that definitively got it
and then in terms of where we go from
here like what are the next inflection
points that you think are important for
the Asian market specifically to kind of
continue to accelerate well I think a
lot of it will depend on you know if you
look at a country like it kind of goes
back to this earlier question of like
how they will strike that balance
between regulatory thoroughness and not
cracking down right so I think if you
look at like a country like Japan
specifically I think they're really
struggling with that where they were
embracing cryptocurrency then they got
tougher this major hack then they became
kind of overly strict and now I think
they're trying to figure out okay like
how do we make sure that like our
exchanges are safe and we're like you
know inspecting these exchanges but with
it not doing so to such an extent that
like nobody wants to come here anymore
so I think that's really the big
question for Asia it's not the question
for everywhere all over the world which
is like how do you find that balance
between like regulation and like
tolerance you know so I think that's
what we're gonna we're gonna keep seeing
and and you know and it's it there's
always going to be these tests right
because a government I mean can be very
accepting towards cryptocurrency then
they suffer a major hi
or there's some major scam and like are
they going to be able to really keep
going after that after public opinion
turns I mean that's kind of what
happened in Japan five hundred million
dollar hack it's not a small thing right
so you know all of the sudden you're
gonna have a lot of people being like
this industry is shady you know and then
Japanese authorities I think
understandably are gonna say like is
this worth it is this really worth it so
that's gonna be the big tension going
forward but I think we're gonna also see
increasing competition in the region
right and I think you know because as
and this is you know even for China I
mean I think China you know China is can
be wary of Bitcoin but they embrace
blockchain technology because I don't
think they want to miss out on this
either what do you think it's the most
important company in crypto right now
I'm super interested in your answer
specifically I'm given that you have a
global view the most important of the
most important company in crypto so I
end each podcast with rapid-fire
questions and that's the first question
is what is the most important company in
crypto oh man the most important company
in crypto
all right I'm just gonna say finance
yeah that's that's fair yeah why um
because I think I think finance is just
a really interesting example of a
company that's had to navigate through a
lot of different jurisdictions you know
they kind of like left China early
relatively early they left China kind of
before the crackdown because they saw
the writing on the wall they had you
know now they they have a presence in
Singapore it's just a very I just think
finance is just a really fascinating
example of a company that shows that
like they're not beholden to any one
jurisdiction they really are kind of
decentralized because I think some
people think of finances the Chinese
exchange they're up but they're
obviously so much bigger than that now
and I think they've navigated a lot of
regulatory challenges in a way that
they're just kind of like everywhere and
I remember I interviewed cz a while back
and kind of asked him like where he was
based and where the exchange was based
and he was just kind of like I'm a
citizen of the world and that's you know
that's kind of like the whole philosophy
of cryptocurrency right so so he gets
him in he really really really gets it
and I tried to explain to somebody it's
not a show what he believes this right
yes so I think it's just it's just a
really interesting I mean if you're
looking at like how the cryptocurrency
industry is creating a really different
new kind of company you know a company
that's kind of like everywhere and
nowhere I think by Nance is a pretty
good example about that so it's not so
much about whether I think finance is
good or bad I just think they are really
representing a radically new kind of
business model for sure what's the one
regulation you would change if you could
anywhere in the world well I don't think
this is necessarily a regulation but I
think that the United States should find
a way to be more clear and I don't have
like I don't have the answer to that
because I'm not like a securities lawyer
but I think that that's the I guess I
would say that is the regulatory
challenge that I would I would focus on
is how the United States can cite kind
of make their policies a little more
clear to the rest of the world got it we
end each podcast you get ask me one
question but first we talk about aliens
okay
believer non-believer think they're real
okay don't think about that much all
right you're actually the first person
to caveat with that
that's the most 200 people and everyone
acts like they touch think about it all
day long definitely don't think about
that much locking alive aliens I think
they're really nice yeah I mean probably
I think would be my what what is your
logic as to why you probably think
they're real it just sort of makes sense
right I mean the universe is so big it
just I find it hard to believe that like
we're the only ones here that just seems
like that that this seems by the law of
averages there should probably be aliens
somewhere that's yeah I would say having
given little thought to the issue so
that's exactly my thought process right
yes you probably thought about it more
well I mean I've had 200 people come in
here and give me their opinions right so
I've got plenty of ideas but no I it
really comes down to math probability
and it's pretty overwhelming yeah like
in terms of how high probability that
there's other sentiment you know life
somewhere well we find them will they
find us do we is that a good thing where
are they is it in our lifetime are they
already here I'm I've heard at all and
so it's pretty it's pretty fascinating
but what one question do you have for me
to finish up sure so if you could be
totally blunt what do you think is just
kind of like the most overhyped part of
the crypto industry like the kind of the
most you know overrated annoying so many
things just went through my head no the
most overrated part of the crypto
industry this is broad but it's
important there is way too big of a
focus on the technology the technology
actually doesn't matter right and it's
because you can make technology you can
get the end result that you want by
using different pieces of technology and
applying different pieces of technology
different ways right there's like kind
of multiple paths to the same end result
and so people who sit and say yeah but
this piece of technology or this
blockchain or whatever does X Y or Z and
that's better they're not wrong in that
yeah maybe it is faster or cheaper or
more efficient or whatever
but that actually doesn't matter at the
end of the day right the better
technology doesn't always win and it
comes down to other things and so I
think that just in general still today
some of it is because of who are the
early adopters of this stuff who's
building it who's in the industry today
there's a huge focus on the tech the
tech doesn't matter it's right and I
tell them all the time I say you use the
internet every single day and 95% of you
could explain to me how it works right
and you actually don't know that there
was you know 8090 other protocols and
why certain ones won and didn't win and
all it doesn't matter at the end of the
day it's gonna get solved now we need
smart people working on it there's going
to have to be the work done to actually
solve it like all that stuff my point
being that when you're trying to build
products and try to build companies the
technology is only one piece of it and
it's actually not the most important
piece in many cases you know and if you
look at take Google right Google beat
out all the other search engines because
they actually had a better algorithm
right so like that is why they ended up
winning but that's not why they built a
successful company right they build a
successful company because the product
they did a whole bunch of things around
that technology that made it successful
and so I think that ultimately if we can
get away from that focus on a tech and
move to other stuff or at least lessen
our dependence on the story of the tech
we'll be in a much better place over
time
actually it Connecticut follow yeah do
you do you think that the crypto
industry is becoming unnecessarily
complex because I feel like that's sort
of related right like you kind of hear
all these projects that you know they
explain what they're doing and you're
like what you know I mean and I think I
actually personally think this is a
problem because I think we still have
this moment where most people don't even
understand what Bitcoin it's like the
vast majority of people do not
understand what bitcoin is and yet you
have all these projects that are getting
increasingly complex you know to the
extent that you know very few people
outside of their tight inner circle can
understand what they're doing do you
think that's a problem oh absolutely
right here's the best example I have so
recently I was talking to a gentleman
who works at a very large institution
they've got you know 25 plus billion
dollars under management and he said to
me which I'm out Bitcoin and the known
supply schedule right the
disinflationary supply
and he said well if everyone knows that
then isn't it priced in and I said well
if I told you that 100 percent of people
in Bitcoin and crypto know you could say
you could argue that it's priced in but
if I told you that that 100 percent of
Bitcoin and crypto is only 1% of the
world population all of a sudden it's
probably not priced in right and so I
think that is very very similar in other
applications when talking about crypto
is just we all understand Bitcoin to
some degree majority of the world
doesn't right right
we all understand how blockchain works
majority the world does it right right
and then when you get inside of crypto
like a you know my best test for
founder's tell me in two sentences or
less what do you do yeah right and if
you can't do it or there's any sort of
technical jargon or whatever I'm not
interested right and some of it is
because you can't articulate what you do
and also the other piece of it is
because you probably don't do anything
right like you're doing more of like an
intellectual you know kind of Olympic
type event where you're saying oh we
tried to build a faster this or a
cheaper this or whatever that's not
doing something right
it's what problem are you solving what
is the solution that you know I totally
agree with that because I think in
general the whole crypto industry not
the whole crypto industry but much of
the crypto industry just has a
storytelling problem in which we still
haven't really convinced the public why
this is necessary right there's a lot of
people don't even understand why bitcoin
is useful why blockchain technology is
necessary and then when you kind of sort
of skip that step and start talking
about these increasingly complex
products yeah I think you're you're
skipping a really important piece
absolutely well where can people go find
out more about long hash the incubators
the data journalism kind of all the
different things you guys are doing sure
well I mean our data journalism site is
long hashed calm on Twitter where at
long hash data
somebody had long ad long hash that's
psychos on the internet I love it got it
and then where can they find you I am at
Emily D Parker I'm Twitter
and Emilie Parker writes is just my
personal website awesome thank you so
much for coming to do this thank you so
much hey everyone
pop here if you liked this episode of
off the chain and want to help us take
[ __ ] go to the top of the Apple Spotify
and other podcast charts please do us a
favor and rate review and subscribe to
review simply go to the off-the-chain
homepage scroll down until you see the
five blank stars taking 15 seconds to
fill those stars in and leave a quick
review goes a long way in helping us
take the entire crypto ecosystem to the
top of the charts I appreciate you
listening and see you next time on off
the chain